[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein richtig einfaches
rezept um zwar hähnchen aus dem rücken
und weil wir heute kein ganzes andy und
so bereiten die gilt den frust aus dem
ofen in einer tomaten basilikum
rahmsauce und bereitet das ganze zwar
auf dem herzen
es wird kurz angebraten auch die soße
wird kurz gekocht aber dann kommt danach
eben den backofen
das heißt ihr könnt das rezept auch
super vorbereiten und auch bis zu dem
punkt wo man es in den backofen schiebt
einfach vorbereiten in den kühlschrank
stellen oder bei raumtemperatur lagern
je nachdem wie heißt es natürlich
draußen ist und dann einfach kurz vor
dem verzehr in den backofen schieben
dazu gibt's bei uns jetzt ein verband
nudel und passt auch wirklich super man
kann aber morath zum beispiel auch reis
oder kartoffeln dazu reichen ja wann
lohnt sich schon mein lieblings oder
einfach bei uns tolle ist für alle fix
fällt es geht wirklich ohne tüte ohne
gar nichts sagen
das ist ein marquis fix rezept nur
sondern ich kann man piepton reinmachen
ja auf jeden fall einfach frischen
schnell gemacht kohl genau und ich zeige
euch jetzt wie man sie zubereitet zeigen
euch hier vor doch mal die zutaten dafür
brauche ich fünf hähnchenbrustfilets ich
habe ich jeweils einen halben teelöffel
salz und pfeffer einen teelöffel
paprikapulver ich habe hier edelsüß drei
esslöffeln olivenöl eine zwiebel der
mich bereits geschält und gewürfelt 2
knoblauchzehen die sind auch geschält
und gewürfelt 400 gramm passierte
tomaten 150 milliliter gemüsebrühe aus
meiner selbst gemachten früher 150
milliliter sahne eine prise zucker etwas
basilikum etwa eine handvoll und 50
gramm parmesan
es gebe jetzt zuerst einmal zwei
esslöffel olivenöl in eine große pfanne
ich nehme jetzt schon x mal den
gusseisernen topf denn den kann ich
jetzt auf dem herd benutzen und kann ihn
dann auch gleich in den backofen
schieben
falls sie jetzt keine back feste form
habt die auf dem herd benutzen könnt
nehmt einfach jetzt eine ganz normale
pfanne und dann könnt ihr alles in der
auflauf also in eine auflaufform
auflaufform in outlook vom ein
schlichten so ich habe jetzt hier die
hühner brüste die netz bereit
abgewaschen und trocken getupft und die
kann ich jetzt würzen mit salz pfeffer
und paprikapulver das wird jetzt kurz
vermischt und das öl erhitzt sich jetzt
bereits bei mittlerer hitze
[Musik]
sobald dann heißt werden die hühner
bewusste darin angebraten für etwa eine
minute
sobald die angebraten sind nehme ich sie
wieder heraus
jetzt kommt das restliche olivenöl in
die pfanne und da kann ich jetzt die
zwiebel und knoblauch würfel darin
anbraten
das dauerte etwa zwei bis drei minuten
ich habe die hitze ein bisschen runter
gestellt damit sie einfach nicht
verbrennen und lasse es einfach classic
anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt sind die zwiebeln usw jetzt kann
ich die passierten tomaten nehmen und
damit die regeln ablöschen
hier gebe ich jetzt noch den zucker mit
dazu der runde den tomaten geschmack
perfekt ab und dann bekommt nochmal eine
selbstgemachte gemüsebrühe mit dazu und
dafür nehmen dir einfach nach geschmack
und falls ihr keine selbstgemachte brühe
abnehmen da einfach fertige prüm wobei
die wirklich super einfach ist in der
herstellung und sonst halt auch eine
richtig coole resteverwertung also falls
ihr mal zu viel gemüse da habt einfach
als gemüse vorzubereiten
an der stelle schmeckt dir jetzt die
soße bereits mit salz und pfeffer ab
falls ihr noch braucht oder nehmt
einfach noch mal von der gemüsebrühe und
jetzt lasse ich die sauce aufkochen und
dann für etwa fünf minuten einkochen
geht es die tomatensoße soweit jetzt
kann ich hier die sahne zufügen
die könnt ihr natürlich weglassen aber
mit der sahne ist es halt so ein
bisschen weniger und dann wirds halt nur
noch am soße aber wie gesagt könnt ihr
auch gerne weglassen
jetzt gebe ich hier die hähnchenbrüste
wieder rein
da hat auch gerne die brühe auf dem
teller und jetzt stehe ich jedoch den
parmesan drüber dann muss natürlich
immer frisch gerieben werden so schmeckt
am besten
und dann hatte ich noch den basilikum
gebt den auch noch mit rein und dann ist
das gericht bereit für den backofen
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich hier den deckel drauf
und so kann das gericht es in den
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 20 minuten
und die zwischenzeit werde ich nutzen um
nudeln abzukochen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das hähnchen fertig und ich
nehme jetzt ein bisschen was von der
soße und gibt es einfach mit zu den
nudeln
ich mag es nämlich ganz gerne wären so
schön verbunden sind und ihr könnt auch
die soße gerne ein bisschen dicker
machen dh entweder weniger wasser nehmen
oder könnte auch im nachhinein noch an
dicken mit etwas stärke oder im monat
die sorgen nöte schleichwerbung mondamin
zu schleichen ich kann keinem
unternehmen ja jetzt einfach ein
bisschen verrühren und ich hab jetzt
hier schon mal eine hühnchenbrust
aufgeschnitten einfach gerade zum
anrichten
na ja das frage ich mich mal erklärt und
zwar gespannt ich stehe immer vor dem
regal okay und dann heißt für mich pute
oder hähnchen und ich oder immer
hähnchen
warum soll ich nicht bohlen oder warum
warum in dieser zeit verschiedene tiere
also aber es ist ein unterschied
zwischen häger gute nummer groß dann hat
er mir schmeckt hähnchen besser
natürlich geht das ist doch logisch dass
zwei verschiedene tiere ja mach das
jetzt einfach so mit der schöpfkelle ich
weiß ich hab alles was jetzt kommt
gleich nach der kann man leicht kamera
auswahl das ist mehr doppelt waren nicht
echt klasse bitte doch gar nicht scharf
gemacht also ich würde jetzt natürlich
noch chillida zu geben aber wenn die
kinos retten dann wie man menschen und
man richtig kräuter richtig und weiß
manche läuft es gerade das wasser im
mund zusammen
und mein magen liegt mir die kräuter
riechen könnte
das ist wirklich genial
ich kam einfach so lange war super das
morath fertig ist richtig schön kräuter
mäßig wirklich gut mensch ist kräuter
hilfen oder hähnchen viele in die
unkräuter panik basilikum tomaten rahmen
so richtig schmeckt ganz toll und vor
allem sehr einfach mit einfachen zutaten
ich würde jetzt noch beim servieren mit
parmesan bestreuen
das kann man auch machen denn parmesan
haben wir auch in der sünde passt sehr
gut dazu und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachkochen und wünsche euch
einen guten appetit und uns allen hier
auch bis zum nächsten mal tschüss macht
es um mit nach wirklich recht spricht
sogar sehr gut
ohne spaß auch hinter der kamera
du darfst weiterhin nicht aus sagen
konnte was sagen nein meine frage nein
das war bei der doofe frage also morax
wörter gehen bald in den duden kräuter
mäßig zusammen mit cosima bahceli für
deren freund micah eine tennis torte
jetzt kommt das schwierigste fast okay
jetzt eine riesige buttercremetorte mit
geheim botschaft und hier noch ein die
torten queen erobert die in centre court
gefestigten ja es richtig schwenke
wochenserie backt sonntag 15 uhr bei vox
[Musik]
[Applaus]